oh this is under 50 bucks 150 bucks
under 50 bucks what is it two eggs the
whole theme is had I Met You in high
school so you dressed the way you want
to dress in high school she dresses that
way and you take her on your ideal date
boy that's cute show her what it would
have been like if you guys were together
had you guys been 15 or 16. that's cute
though that's right had you guys met at
high school right yeah if we met in high
school she'd be in Elementary School
wait what what does that mean age
difference what does that mean you could
have her stand outside of her Elementary
School
still if it was a high school elementary
school some of us are not trying to go
into that natural place
if I got held back a bunch I'm a super
senior and she's a smart guy smart guy
that's better she's a smart guy I'm just
gonna show her this video and get her
some scrubs